i i filled in for you when you were gone
and you almost did too well
kelly oh whatever i felt nervous i was
like who fills in for freaking simon
cowell
well i gotta hide it because you know we
were a bit of a loose end
and someone said you know do you think
kelly would do i said
i promise you if kelly's free she'll do
it and i was watching literally in bed
that night and i'm thinking
thank you and as i'm watching it i'm
thinking you're actually doing
too well here
i will tell you this though i did i did
put on a little british accent for this
one
i'd like to would you like to see it yes
it's great
i don't like it i love it except i need
glasses and a black shirt
but i'm missing that and then wait
there's another one is
what the bloody hell was that i have the
worst british accent
of the entire universe i don't have i
don't do accents
[Laughter]
nope where are you from the buyer y'all
like a barbecue
block some ribs okay you're about as
good as my accident
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help